when we talk about your money on this
show and right now prominent in the news
is the GOP tax proposal to lower taxes
and people of course are going bananas
on both sides of the aisle I'm amazed at
how many people lose their ability to do
critical thought due to their political
beliefs that you get your head stuck so
far up your politics you can't think
clearly I'm amazed at that both on the
right and the left some people that I
know that are otherwise intelligent when
they view something through a political
lens lose their ability to think about
things I'll give you an example of that
taxation is not a charitable Act period
you don't to be left right purple or
green to figure that one out taxation is
not a charitable Act and so to accuse
someone who doesn't want to pay higher
taxes as being uncharitable towards poor
people is absolutely absurd it's
ridiculous
a charitable Act is when someone
voluntarily takes money that they have
owned and earned and they give it to
someone else through some methodology
voluntarily if they do not do that they
do not go to jail if you don't pay your
taxes failure to file as a criminal act
2561 people went to jail last year for
not paying federal income taxes it is a
criminal act so there's nothing
charitable or loving the poor well about
thinking people should be taxed more and
on top of that everybody that think is
there anyone out there real I mean
there's there might be someone it's
there
you can find someone that believes any
stupid thing but I would venture to say
99.9% of people walking around listening
this show right now would not say that
government is an efficient way to do
anything I mean even if you're the left
of the left winger even if your right
wing doesn't flap you know you just fly
in circles just because you got one wing
I mean some right wingers are that way
too right but even if you're that person
you can't say that government is an
efficient way to do anything and people
in the military do a wonderful job but
people in the military will tell you the
military's not even efficient I was
meeting with a five-star general he said
you know we're told you know our whole
purpose is to do one thing kill people
and we're not even always efficient at
that you know they'll tell you guys and
gals that are in the military to tell
you I mean it's it's it's an inefficient
process meaning it's a bad use of money
not the military but just the government
so if you wanted to accomplish a task
whatever task it is you would always
accomplish the task more efficiently
more quickly with more productivity and
more often a higher probability of the
test being accomplished if you did it
anyway other than through the government
you have to think that way I mean
otherwise you're just being completely
illogical or you have to think that the
task would never be done at all unless
government did it that would be a
reasonable way of looking at it I guess
there's some things that just wouldn't
happen unless government did them
understand that and so the people that
are going bananas about this and I'm not
taking up for Republicans I'm certainly
not taking up for Donald Trump not even
a chance of that but this idea that
lowering taxes on anyone is a bad idea
because government is so caring and
loving
is absolutely ridiculous you guys
government is not caring and loving
government is not efficient government
hardly ever gets done what it's supposed
to do and if it does it didn't do it
well I mean you name me one thing that
they operate there you go wow that was
an amazing user experience the customer
service was freakin five-star you tell
me one thing that that happens when
you're dealing with the government wow I
just changed my life
wow what a customer experience no we get
the DMV that's what we get with
everything and so if you want to help
poor people if you really want to help
poor people if you really care about
children that are hungry you really care
about 52% of single moms live below the
poverty level you have to understand
government is not going to do it you're
the way to do it you're the answer it
starts with you your generosity your
charitable giving and one of my goals
it's a lofty goal I doubt I'll actually
hit it but I would love to is to
influence enough people to build enough
wealth with enough generosity that we
give so much to actual causes that do
matter children that are hungry single
moms that are struggling the homeless
people who are marginalized that we the
people directly use our money without
compulsion from the government or
through an inefficient government
program give so much that you listening
to me increase your generosity so much
that you make the government irrelevant
and then it takes away the argument of
we need to pay more taxes because if you
don't believe you evil conservatives if
you don't believe in high taxes for
everyone you really hate poor people
that's what you're saying let me tell
you I don't care if you're rich okay if
you're poor I don't care if you're
middle class it's your money and they
shouldn't be taking as much of it as
they take even rich people should be
allowed to keep their own money even
rich people should be able to keep their
own money because by the
it's their money it's not yours it's
their money it's not yours
this is not socialism yet it's their
money it's not yours and poor people
should be able to keep more of their
money it's their money they need it it's
not yours
well this tax cut is only it's gonna
cost this I saw one reports gonna cost
this group you know four hundred and
sixty one dollars more next year if you
make seventy five thousand dollars if
you make seventy five thousand dollars
and four and sixty one dollars changes
your life you don't have a life let me
help you with that that's the government
that's government's form of generosity
that's their inefficient methodology of
generosity you they're gonna cut they're
gonna take a whole bunch of your money
and then decide they're not gonna take
quite as much of it and make you feel
good about them let me just tell you
that's a clown show up they're clowns to
the left of me Joker's to the right you
remember him
Steve Miller right that's a clown show
up there and don't let them tell you on
either side of the aisle that they've
got your best interests at heart they
have one thing in their heart and that's
get reelected that's it and they think
by tinkering around with your money and
making you think they did you a favor
that you're gonna be happy with them on
either side of the aisle you're in
charge of your life remember that hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh